へいへい
あああああ
皆さんはじめまして株式会社ムスカ代表取締役 ceo の竜号文乃と申します
よろしくお願いします本日はですね
自然が持つ循環する力を活用して地球にやさしい未来を創っていこう
まじ取材時静大のためにというようなお話をするんですけど
まず初めに私のは少し
パーソンの自己紹介からさせていただきたいなと思ってます
ミレニアム世代私自身はそうなるんですけれども
二人の子供を持っている母親でもありまして
7歳が息子ですねで救済が娘となるんですけど
で私自身は都会にずっと住んでいました
そして誰かに住んでいてからっていうのもあるんですけど虫が本当に嫌いな人であるの
でまぁ都会に住んでて牛が嫌い結構普通の女性だなというふうに自分自身を持ってたり
するんですけど実は
なぜか廃炉会社に入りました
そしてですねまあ今敏の会社の代表取締役をしていたりもします
なんでがのって結構いろんな方々からなぜかっていうことを聞かれることが多いんです
けれども
私の子供たちのさっき7歳9歳といったんですけどその子供たちが80歳になったとき
いいおじいちゃんとおばあちゃんであるっていうことなんですけどこの授業が面白いか
面白くないかもすなわちそれは社会の役に立つかだと
かそういったことを言ってたりするんですけど
その
ドハマりだった事業が生えの会社に入ったきっかけなんですね
ただ今でもやっぱり虫嫌いで本当に何ですかねそれだけはちょっと治らない
なんだけどやっぱ彼らのことを本当に尊敬してます
それはあの生え自身て私はすごく厄介らしいが嫌いだ
4いや黙っていう感情しかまあネガティブな感情しかなかったんですけど
地球上が地球上にその彼らの役割っていうのがあるんだなっていうことを知った時に
すごく面白いと思っていて私たち人類っていうのが生きるよ僕年前から生えって実は
存在していてしかも
すごいのがなんていうか4億年前からその姿ってほとんど変わってないんですね
4くれ前からあの姿カタチ変えることなく
恐竜族とかは絶滅してはいますけどでもハエとか昆虫ってほとんど形が変わることなく
ずっと憤慨していて何で
地球上にその彼らの存在する
存在し続けられるのかというところが非常に面白いなと思っていて
で1頭で何で私たちってハエ嫌いだったのかな
まあ今も嫌いなんだけどなんでハエが嫌いなのかなっていうところなんですけどまず
このワードが皆さんの頭に浮かぶんじゃないかなと思っていて汚い
そうですね来たな衛生害虫とかそういった言葉が浮かぶと思うんですけどなんで汚い
ところにいるのかなっていうふうに考えたときにちょっと面白くて
あの
改めて地球上に彼らメイクへ彼らの1塁役割というか存在する役割というのを考えぷと
やっぱり自然をちょっと想像していただきたいんですけど
自然界の中には動物のフンとかも落ちていてその糞っていうのにハエがたかってたり
するわけですよね
まだからやだなっていう心理的に思うわけですけど
でもそれで集ってはいは卵を産んだりするわけですよ
卵産んでそしたら速は次幼虫になるんですけど
幼虫になったらそれを彼らは分解するんですねその私たちが汚いと思っている動物の
フンとか分解して言って分解したらその次その[ __ ]だったものっていうのは
豊かな土壌に変わるわけですね豊かな土壌に代わっていてはい自身はまあサナギになっ
て成虫になっていく流れの中で
鳥に食べられたりとかさ仮面食べられたりするんだけどそういう自然のサイクルって
いうのがすごく面白くってハエって何だかその汚いもの私たちから見てすごく汚い物
っていうのを
分解している存在なんだなというふうに感じたときに結構入っていい奴がなっていう
ふうに思ってハエ自体役はどうしても嫌いはまあ今困難嫌いなんですけどでも彼ら自体
がやっていることを地球ちょうどずーっと行ってきたことっていうのは本当に
素晴らしいことだなというのとあーの
尊敬できるところだなっていうふうに思ってたりします
だから本当に効果的に
生えていうのはもうハエの幼虫だったりはいもそうですけど
地球のお掃除をしているんだなっていうふうに感じています
さてここから話がすごく変わるんですけどまずその栄え
覚えておいて下さいねちょっといい奴だったかっていうのをみなさん
なんとマーク感じてくれたかなと思うんですけど
地球の
規模で大きな問題があって廃棄物の増加っていうのと
食糧不足コレっていうのは人口が爆増する2050年に向けてもどうしようもなくって
好状態だから解決しなければいけない問題っていう風になってたりします
もうちょっとフォーカス当てて今回は有機廃棄物処理について
ごはん
足をしたいなと思うんですけどまず昆虫テクノロジーっていうものを使って行き廃棄物
を適切に効果的に処理をしていきましょうという風なお話なんですが
6,400,000といけない数字出てきたんだけどこれって何の数字かみなさん
わかりますか
これはですねフードロス皆さんが食べ残したりそういった数字だったりするんですけど
食品廃棄物と大きなくるくくりでいうと約3千万トンくらい
年間3排出されていますでもうちょっと口サプライチェーンさかのぼっていくと皆さん
お肉食べますかねもちろん今さ
一気に食べない方も増えてきたんですけどごみ約8000万と年間ではい撥水している
ゴミっていうのは家畜の排せつ物のゴミ
有機廃棄物になるんですけどこれらの問題というのはどういう風に処理されている
かって言うとですね
無知ほど説明したいんですけどまずフードすっ
皆さんよくご存知で6,400,000党なんですけど
家畜の排せつ打ってももすごく量が多いでこの量が多い状態で
98%微生物の発酵処理というもので処理されています
この微生物の発酵処理をする過程の中で
まず1年間かけてすごくイイ一秒ができるんですね
ただ1年間かかるその過程の中で
で温室効果ガスっていうのが出ていてそれを出しながら空気に触れさせながら発酵させ
て処理をさせる今は米やり方が98%
残り2%
っていうのがバイオガス発言とかバイオマス発電とかそういった処理のされ方をしてい
ます
でもうちょっと考えてほしいんですけど自然界にいる物って存在するものっていうのは
微生物だけだったかなっていうふうに考えていただきたくて
今は家畜の排せつ物を微生物だけに頼って
処理してるわけですよでも自然界って昆虫いますよね
はいもいるわけですよ皆さん嫌いな通りでだからそのハエを活用して自然界のサイクル
を応用していきたいなと思っています
それが昆虫テクノロジーで自然から学ぶ
循環型の新しいテクノロジーっていうのをご紹介したいと思うんですけど
まず家畜の排せつ物まあさっきの自然界のストーリーを創造そのまま想像してもらえれ
ばいいんですけどそこに入りの卵を置きます
だいたい1日厳密に言うと8時間ぐらいで蒸してくれる
ですけどそうすると幼虫になるわけですね幼虫の消化酵素でそのゴミを分解して
1週間という短期間で拙い文回打って有機肥料ができます
幼虫自身は蛹になりたいと思うので別に分けてサナギになってくれるんですけどそれを
家畜の飼料であったり養殖の資料にしていくんですねこのサイクルっていうのは微生物
と
昆虫分けた時に1年間で
一つの資源詩ができませんっていうのが微生物もやり方でした
でもうこんなに待ってられないから23カ月で終わらし被って馬国内やっているところ
がほとんどなんですけどそうするとその未熟な肥料っていうのを巻いていて
土壌の汚染とかまあ水質汚染とかそういったものにつながっているんですね
で昆虫に変えましょうとそうすると1週間で
2つの資源ができるわけです昆虫を活用することで
まず有機肥料1週間で分解できますそして
幼虫自身が出てくることで幼虫は食べていただけるっていうエサとして家畜とか夕食に
食べられるというような状態が作れるんです
にこれってまあ
家畜まあそれこそ昔庭先で家畜を飼っているのであれば微生物でよかったんです
バランスがとれてた状態だと思うんですけど今って畜産っていうのはもう
畜産業っていう形になっていて業界になってるわけで
そうすると微生物では全然賄えない状態になっているわけなんですよ
ですでそれを
ちょっと昆虫活用することでもちろん畜産の排泄物の中に微生物でいないわけじゃない
のでそれに昆虫をあえて人的に与えることによってそれをバランス整えるカタチにし
ませんかっていうのが昆虫テクノロジー
自然界のサイクルというもの王様だと思っています
ですね人類と自然って言って結構
自然と人類てもすごく違う形でをハメされることが多いんですけど
自然界の中に人類がいて破壊していくのではなくって
自然と人類っていうのは常に一緒分一緒なので競争していく
だからこそテクノロジー
が生まれている pop 人類の力っていうのを自然に応用したテクノロジーの発想
っていうのを作っていきたい作っていける時代になるだろうと思っていて
環境と産業とか社会と産業とかって結構対立構造で言われることが多いんですけど
対立しない世の中っていうのは
くっていかなければいけないっていうふうに思っています
すべての産業っていうのが今井3g ずとかもありますけれどもそういうの抜きにして
も遺族可能な循環型の社会というのを見つけていかなければいけないっていう風に考え
ていてだからこそいろんな産業の人たちというのは自然にもっともっと学んで自然が
持つ循環する力っていうのを活用して
で私たち自身次世代に向けて地球にやさしい未来というのを作っていきたいのという
ふうに思っています
ありがとうございます